the horror of horoscopes in newspapers across
the country you will find a segment devoted
to those who need to know what will happen
in the future and there are segments for
different months of the year if you're born
in july you go read july and if you're nosy
you read what happens to people who are born
in august then of course there's the zodiac
and people believe in that sort of thing
whether you're a libra or aries or whatever
the other things are and people guide their lives
and make decisions based on these sources of
information and they take it very very seriously
i'm sure you're very well aware that nancy reagan
is public knowledge used to consult what
you call them well people was that psychic
the child of god needs to know
what the bible says about that kind of
practice and the power behind all varieties
of that pursuit for knowledge that perhaps
we should not have the horror of horoscopes
in genesis 3 reading from verse 1 turn there with
me please genesis chapter 3 reading from verse 1.
genesis 3 reading from verse 1
the bible says now the serpent was more
subtle than any beast of the field which
the lord god had made and he said
unto the woman yea hath god said
he shall not eat of every tree of the garden
notice the description of the serpent the serpent
was more subtle than any beast of
the field which the lord god had made
now the lord made the serpent subtle and cunning
and wise some animals are smarter than others
i am told elephants never forget chimpanzees very
smart dolphins seals some animals are smarter
than others the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the lord god had made
and he said unto the woman yea hath god said
ye shall not eat of every tree of the garden
the woman said unto the serpent we may eat
of the fruit of the trees of the garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is
in the midst of the garden god hath said
ye shall not eat of it neither
shall he touch it lest ye die
and the serpent said unto the woman ye shall not
surely die now god had said in genesis 2 17 in the
there thou eatest thereof thou shalt surely die
the serpent said ye shall not surely die all he
did was to add one word essentially and change
the meaning from north to south black to white
life to death and in verse five he said for god
doth know that in the day thereof then your eyes
shall be opened and ye shall be as gods knowing
good and evil here's what the devil told eve god
knows that if you eat of this fruit your
eyes shall be opened and ye shall be as
gods knowing good and evil now the expression
good and me evil simply means all there is to know
i have told you many times in god's system in
god's kingdom there is no such thing as neutrality
you're right on one side or the other the bible
always gives mankind a choice do right do wrong
serve god serve the devil you're saved you're
lost your sheep your goat your wheat your tare
you're with me or you're against me you scatter
with me you gather with me you scatter against me
that is the way the bible is there's no middle
ground the devil says you shall be as gods
knowing good and evil in ecclesiastes 12 13 14
let us hear the conclusion of the whole matter
fear god and keep his commandments for this
is the whole duty of man for god shall bring
every work into judgment with every secret
thing whether it be what good or evil that
includes every work into judgment and all that a
person can do comes under one of two headings good
or evil and so the devil is really saying
ye shall be as gods knowing everything
and this is a temptation that
people cannot resist up to this day
we want to know everything we want to know what
will happen tomorrow we want to invade areas of
knowledge that god has not planned for us to
invade at least not according to our schedule
ye shall be as god's knowing good and evil you'll
know everything this being that tempted eve has
a history let's do a short biographical
sketch of this being called the devil 7 19
90 minutes after seven the
bible says in ezekiel chapter 28
reading from verse 11 ezekiel 28 reading from
verse 11 and i'm reading publicly from the
king james version for those of you who are
following ezekiel 28 reading from verse 11.
ezekiel says moreover the word of the
lord came unto me saying son of man
take up a lamentation upon the king of tyrus
and say unto him thus saith the lord god
thou sealest up the son full of wisdom and
perfect in beauty this is a description of lucifer
after he sinned he became satan or the devil the
dragon the serpent thou seelest up the sun we have
a saying in our modern language when god made me
what did he do he broke the mold that's that's a
modern version of what ezekiel is saying lucifer
was at that time god's highest expression of his
creative power lucifer was god's signature on the
colossal universal canvas of his creation lucifer
represented the highest the high tide
expression of god's divine creation
and so the bible says thou see list of the sun
there's nothing beyond this full of beauty and
perfect in beauty and full of wisdom verse
13 thou hast been in eden the garden of god
every precious stone was thy covering now
here's a description of how we looked on
the outside the sardius topaz and diamond
the beryl onyx and jasper the sapphire
emerald carbuncle and gold now these are ten
precious stones that covered him on the outside
the only creature god ever made
and put jewelry on him was lucifer
if you want to call that precious stones all over
him verse 13 goes on to say the workmanship of thy
tabrets and of thy pipes was prepared in thee from
the day that thou was created i would have loved
to have heard that creature saying before he fell
his tablets and his pipes were prepared in him
i've heard some people say and i tend to
agree before lucifer sin probably still
can when he opened his mouth as saying he
probably all by himself sang soprano alto
tenor and bass all by himself a glorious creature
verse 14 ezekiel 28 thou art the anointed cherub
that covereth and i have set this soul notice
not the anointed cherubim the anointed cherub
lucifer was the only one when god told moses to
construct the ark now we're introduced to cherubim
there were two one on either side in the days
of lucifer his unfallen days he was the only
one and god hand-picked him the verse 14 says
thou art the anointed cherub that covereth
and i have set this soul you know there's some
people called headhunters they go looking for
special people to fill special positions
god specially laid his hand on lucifer for
a very specific work and that work was to serve as
close to god as any created being could serve no
other angel could come that close to god no other
angel lucifer served in the very presence of god
a seraph cherub all combined in one when
lucifer came from the presence of god we
know what happened to moses when he came
off the mountain what happened to his face
shining when jesus is on the mount of
transfiguration what happened to his clothes they
begin to shun like like like lightning lucifer
coming out of the presence of god must have
shone with all those precious
stones and the light flashing and
chorus skating he must have been a
sight flying through the vault of heaven
lucifer was as close to christ
as any created being could look
verse 15 tells us ezekiel 28 that was perfect
in thy ways in the day that that was created
until iniquity was found in thee that is
all the bible tells us about sin that was
perfect in thy ways and from the day thou
was created from day one lucifer was perfect
then somehow mysteriously sin began
in this created being verse 17
thine heart was lifted up because of thy beauty
that has corrupted thy wisdom by reason of thy
brightness somehow lucifer felt because of how he
looked and the powers he had he deserved a higher
place and how much like us this attitude is we're
always striving for higher places where perhaps
god has not called us suited us nor fitted us and
lucifer reached beyond what god intended for him
and of course god has to cast him out let's go
get some more information about this creature
isaiah chapter 14 reading verses 13 and
14. isaiah 14 reading verses 13 and 14.
let's read verse 12 get some connection isaiah
says how fallen from heaven oh lucifer sun of
the morning how thou cut down to the ground which
this weakened the nations for thou has said in
thine heart i will ascend into heaven i will
exalt my throne above the stars of god i will
sit also upon the mount of the congregation in
the sides of the north i will ascend above the
heights of the clouds i will be like the most high
lucifer goes from being the closest angel to god
now he wants to be god he wants to be
like the most high accountable to no one
his own law no one can tell him anything
let's learn some more about this creature
let's go to john chapter 8 verse 44.
this is jesus christ himself speaking
john 8 44 as we continue the horror
of horoscopes 26 minutes after 7
jesus says ye are of your father the devil
and the lust of your father you will do
he was a what a murderer how far back from the
beginning way back before adam and eve were made
he made an attempt on the life of christ
of course christ wasn't called christ back
then second member of the godhead
just the son but he made an attempt
that's why revelation 12 7 tells us and there
was war in heaven michael and his angel fought
against the dragon now he is the dragon having
sinned michael jesus christ fought against the
dragon and his angels and the dragon fought
and his angels and prevailed not neither was
their place found any more in heaven and the
great dragon was cast out that old serpent
called the devil and satan who deceiveth
the whole world that's his forte deception
and deception works best on a man or a
woman who thinks he or she knows everything
because that person does not have to defend and
that was what lucifer offered or satan offered eve
and by extension adam knowing everything good
and evil there was a war christ threw him out
verse 13 of revelation 12 tells us when the dragon
saw he was cast unto the earth he persecuted the
woman which brought forth the man child that
verse simply tells us that the devil now that
he no longer can go back to heaven he vents
his fury and his anger on the people of god
now the devil came to eve
in genesis 3 not as himself
satan never comes as himself he comes disguised
and he always comes disguised attractively
so he came as a serpent and his method
of deception was smooth it was tempting
his voice was probably musical and he lured eve
into his web and in verse 6 of genesis 3 the
bible says and when the woman saw that the tree
was good for food now notice in verse 3 she said
we may eat of the fruit of the trees of the garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is in the midst
of the garden god have said he shall not eat
of it neither shall he touch it lest he die she
said that now in verse six the bible says when
the woman saw that the tree was good for food she
saw it was good for food because she had
fallen to the deceptions of the enemy
let me tell you something never argue
with the devil or his agents stand fast
and firm on the word of god come on more amens
than that stand fast stand firm on the word of god
when the devil spoke to eve in the garden of eden
eve was surrounded by proof and evidence that
god's word has power she had no proof the devil's
word had power what do i mean here's what i mean
even knew how the earth was created and god said
god loves to tell his children how he
works that's the way he is he loves to
tell them jesus said john 15 15 all things i've
heard of my father i have made known unto you
john 14 verse 2 if it were not so i
would have told you god loves to tell
eve knew god said let there be light there was
light let the earth bring forth grass there was
grass let the earth bring forth the living
creature after his kind she knew everything
she saw came into existence by the powerful
word of god and the same word that said let
there be grass said if you eat you will die the
word didn't change in power when the devil said
you shall not surely die eve had a choice thou
shalt not surely die or thou shalt surely die
and with no proof that the devil's word has power
with no evidence visual audible kinesthetic or
any other way she chose the devil's word
there are people making religious choices
attending churches with no biblical evidence
whatsoever other than somebody else's word
they have no authority in the word of god but
they do it just because somebody else had it
eve had no proof the devil's word had power she
followed him just because he said it beautifully
why do you worship the way you worship let me
digress because you have verification in scripture
or because someone said so with no bible proof
why do you worship the way you worship because
it's a family tradition or because it's a biblical
tradition why do we worship the way we worship
because it is the habit or the custom of our tribe
or is the custom that originated in heaven
why do we worship the way we worship
now this devil his strong point is still deception
and in no area is his deception more difficult
to detect than in the area called spiritualism
730 731 spiritualism is more than simply
dead people coming out of a grave and
their eyes rolling back in their heads and
spirits flying around in white sheets and
jasper the friendly ghost getting stuck in a
refrigerator spiritualism is more than that
spiritualism is any effort to remove
christ from the throne of our hearts
let me tell you that again spiritualism
is any attempt to remove christ as lord
now he can stay a savior but he cannot stay as
lord in other words save me and leave me alone
save me let me live my life as i please that's
i want him a savior i don't want him as lord
spiritualism is any attempt to remove
christ from his rightful place on our hearts
as sovereign of our lives by the profession that
we have made to be his children there are people
who preach that god's biggest attribute
is love so all you have to do is love
obedience is not important that is a teaching
of spiritualism that is almost never detected
now i just said any movement that removes christ
from your heart is spiritualism any movement any
teaching that puts distance between you and
obedience to god's law is surely spiritualist
because sin is a transgression of god's law
if you believe that all you have to do is love
and obedience is part of the old
covenant you are on a beautifully paved
spiritualist pathway and it is sloping
downward and at the end there's a fire
the devil told eve he shall not surely die
that is believed up to this day because people
believe in their hearts that when
you die you are not really dead
every person with a public reputation
who is talked about on television after
that person passes away someone almost
always says but he's safe now in heaven
apparently no one ever stays
in the grave he is safe
regardless of who the person is al capone died
he is now in heaven resting some baseball player
dies he is now on the big diamond in the sky
i'm not joking i'm telling you what i've heard
regardless of the person's life however
immoral and sinful and wicked and depraved
and degenerate that person was
and i don't mean to judge people
at their death feel compelled to say
that person is in heaven i have never
at any funeral and i have gone to more than
i can count hear anyone say he is now in hell
i have never heard it has anyone of you heard it
never now am i to understand no one has ever died
who deserves to go to hell everyone goes to heaven
because it is based on the belief that
when you die something remains alive
the bible says in ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse
5 and verse 6 i hope you write these verses down
7 35 we have 25 minutes together somebody
say amen ecclesiastes 9 verses 5 and 6
for the living know that they
shall die but the dead know
nothing neither have they any
more reward for the memory of
them is forgotten not that people forget
them but the dead can no longer remember
also they love and they hate and the envious
perish neither have there any more a portion
for ever in anything that is done under
the sun a dead person cannot participate
in anything that goes on on this
earth that's what ecclesiastes 9
6 say neither have their apportioned forever
in anything that is done under the sun
which means my grandfather who died cannot
come and participate in my life by telling me
anything i was in a australia i may
have mentioned this to you earlier
met this young lady i won't say what country she's
from but she was going back to visit the family
and the first stop after she arrived it was the
first time they would see her after she completed
some advanced degree they would go to a shrine
and offer food to dead people that's not the right
expression ancestors and she was nervous about
it because she had been touched by the gospel
and was caught between pleasing god and profoundly
hurting her family and she was in a in a crisis
and we told her we would just pray for her
when she got there she sent back an email
we got the news one of her sisters hallelujah
supported her in her decision to be christian
and supporting her in her
decision not to go to the shrine
i said a young lady refused to go
to satan's place i get to amens
you know someone sent me a card and said pastor
don't be so hard on us some of us have not been
raised to say amen is that true can i see your
hands those of you who have not been raised to
say amen where are you okay let me teach
you quickly in one second come on say amen
say it again say it again now you can't use
that excuse anymore now you know how to say
a man but she refused to go to that shrine because
she'd been convicted there are people who believe
i've met people who came to me i need prayer
why i'm under curse how do you know that
my mother said so my aunt before she
died she said i am cursed i will never
get married never finish my education never
get a job and they believed it and so they
subconsciously decided not to get married not
to get a job or not to get not to get education
and so they chose to fulfill this dying person's
curse there are people untold millions of people
living under the burden of this satanic
deception that powers on the other side can
influence their lives yes they can but they are
not dead people and i won't go into all i went
into this this morning about text you can use
for talking about the state of the dead because
i want to talk about something else if you
want those texts i can give them to you later
there are beings called demons let's go to
revelation 12 let's go there quickly now i'll
pause and wait for you to get revelation
12. you have to see this revelation 12
reading verse 7 again we just read it we'll
read that again it's almost 20 minutes to 8.
the bible says reading from verse 7 revelation
12 and there was war in heaven michael and
his angels fought against the dragon and the
dragon fought and his angels and prevailed not
neither was their place found any more in heaven
pause before i say what i want to say about demons
notice what the bible says michael and his angels
fought now if you have the king james read with me
loudly i want you to see this read with me now
michael and his angels i can't hear you fought
against the dragon and the dragon fought and his
angels read the next few words by yourself loudly
that's not loud enough read it again when
you fight in the name of jesus the devil
cannot prevail against you they fought
and prevailed not they fought and lost
when you fight christ you lose when you fight
with christ you win and the devil fought and
his angels and prevailed not we have to take
that into our hearts as a living principle
it is the devil that brings bad habits to us
it is the devil that gets us in all kinds of
trouble he can't force us but we cooperate he is
the motivating power he is the instigating force
he prevailed not and as he did not prevail
in heaven he need not prevail in our lives
the devil has a track record of defeat
he has not won one battle when he
comes up against jesus christ not one
and the last one that's coming
he will learn that painfully
now michael and his angels fought against
the dragon and the dragon fought and what
his angels the devil has angels that were cast out
with him neither was this place found anymore in
heaven and the great dragon was cast out that
old serpent called the devil and satan wished
to see with the whole world this first line he was
cast out into the earth and his angels were cast
out with him now we have the angels are evil let's
go to second peter chapter two reading verse four
the angels are evil we're looking at this demonic
power that's responsible for all the spiritualism
in the world the devil cannot force us to
practice it but he encourages people to do that
and he must be exposed second
peter chapter two verse four
for if god spared not the angels that did
what that sin but cast them down to hell
deliver them into chains of darkness to be
reserved unto judgment the angels that sinned
but there's some angels in heaven that
didn't sin they are the good ones so
paul says in galatians chapter 1 let's go
there reading verse 8 galatians 1 verse 8.
as we continue the heart of horoscopes galatians
1 verse 8 paul says paul is so angry that the
galatians are leaving the pure gospel he says for
thou we are what an angel from where heaven they
are good angels preach any other gospel unto you
than that which we have preached to you let him
be accursed there are angels in heaven let's go
to hebrews chapter 1 verse 14. as we continue the
heart of horoscopes and the horror of horoscopes
is that the power in the horoscope is the power
of the devil himself either directly or through
his angels that the bible refers to as demons
when a man is demon-possessed or woman that is the
power of a fallen angel in that person and i have
seen it myself personally i don't go looking for
it but from time to time in evangelism you come
up against it and you have to be ready to face
it and you can only face it as jesus faced it
what verse did i say
hebrews 1 14 are they not what all ministering
spirits sent forth to minister to them
who shall be ears of salvation those are the
good angels let's go to psalm 34 7. psalm 34 7.
beautiful sam read it tonight please a beautiful
sound see how god loves people who are genuinely
penitent and broken-hearted and eager and willing
to confess their sins god is always willing to
listen read that whole psalm you'll never see
the same way again read psalm 34 verse 7 says
the angel of the lord encampeth rang about them
that fear him and does what deliver of them yes
let me show you something else about
angels matthew 28 reading from verse 1.
matthew 28 reading from verse 1
you have it in the end of the sabbath as it
began to dawn toward the first day of the week
came mary magdalene and the other mary to
see the sepulcher and behold there was what
an earthquake for the angel of the lord
descended and came and rolled back the stone
from the door and sat upon it now one angel
came down to christ's tomb and what happened
there was an earthquake that's how powerful angels
are now some angels are more powerful than others
because gabriel is now the most powerful angel
in heaven that's the one that went to daniel
that's the one that went to zechariah the father
of john the baptist gabriel describes himself as
he that stands in the very presence of god angels
are powerful some more powerful than others now
wicked angels some are more wicked than others
let's go to luke chapter 11. reading from verse 24
16 minutes to eight luke 11 reading from verse
24. the horror of horoscopes and it's a very
terrible horror we're talking about the power
of the devil christ's sworn enemy and yours and
mine when the unclean spirit has gone out of a
man he walketh through dry places seeking rest
and finding none he saith i will return unto my
home once i came out and when he cometh he findeth
it swept and garnished then goethe and taketh
to him seven other spirits you read the rest
more wicked than himself yes there are
some spirits more wicked than others
heaven is organized the kingdom of darkness is
organized satan has some spirits that are wicked
those are the ones he sends after the preachers
don't say amen don't say amen serious business
more wicked than himself
now when you go to the psychic when you go to
the necromancer when you go to that dark room
where bells start tingling and chairs start
moving when you go to get your palms red
when you go to have tea leaves red
when i go to have cards cut and red
or if i'm in some remote area have a goat
slit open and there's entrails cast out on
the ground and some man sits down and reads
it like a book what's the power the devil
these angels were wise when god made
them they have not lost that wisdom
when god sent plague number 10 what was that
plague he sent on egypt number 10 what was it
what was it the destroying how
many angels did god send one
how many first born were killed in egypt all
people and animals how many angels did it one
now you understand our scripture reading
for we wrestle not against flesh and blood
you see when someone does you something wrong
you see the person you hear the person you
can interact with the person on the sensory
level i see you i hear you i may smell you
it'll touch you i i you make sense to me but
the power behind that person we cannot see
and so paul tells the christian you must you
must be able to manage your anger reserve
some for the unseen power behind that person
for we wrestle not against flesh and blood
but churches spend all their lives rustling
flesh and blood that side of the church
rustles with this side of the church and the
devil sits back in the front row and applauds
the scripture tells us we wrestle not against
flesh and blood but against principalities against
powers against the rulers of the darkness of this
world against spiritual wickedness in high places
now notice again these are all negative
listen again to ephesians 6 10
for we wrestle not against flesh
against principalities against powers against the
rulers of the darkness of this world 10 to 12.
let's go to colossians 1 16 see something where
do these principalities and powers come from
12 minutes to wait the horror of horoscopes
colossians 1 16 says for by him were how many
things created all that are in heaven and that
are in earth visible and invisible whether they
be thrones or dominions or principalities or
powers the same thing we read in
ephesians 6 10 to 12 meaning they
are good principalities and powers and they are
bad principalities and powers they all began good
but at satan's instigation they fell these
are the powers we are up against listen to me
a demon can appear in the form
of a long departed relative
speak with a person's voice look like the person
same clothes same everything if you
and i are not grounded in god's word
and someone appears in your room tonight
so your grandmother died 20 years ago and you see
your grandmother sitting on the side of your bed
and your grandmother says
whatever your name is methuselah
you don't have to keep the sabbath anymore
i came from the other side and they don't
keep it over there you don't have to keep
it anymore in a musical voice like a flute
and your knees are knocking but
all you see is your grandmother
who used to bake your cookies and
defend you from your mother's wrath
and so you listen and you and
you sweat and you shake and the
the apparition ventures and you're
convinced my grandmother came back
and gave me some instruction and
so you no longer keep the sabbath
how many times people have committed murder
because they heard a voice tell them kill somebody
i believe i read somewhere i have to say i believe
one of our pioneers and if you're not an adventist
when we say pioneers we mean those people who
sacrifice life limb possessions property comfort
ease luxury to build up this church somebody
say amen and i admire them i love to read
their writings god bless them i want to see them
in the resurrection one of them lost his wife
and of course when you lose a loved
one your perception is affected because
grief does things to the mind and one
day the wife appeared in the bedroom
and but this pioneer was a man of the book
the apparition looked just like his wife sitting
on the bed or standing wherever she was or it was
and might have said something to him
hello honey hello darling how are you
he stood up what do you think he did he
rebuked the devil in the name of jesus
and he said when he when he spoke the rebuke
i'm sure his blood was ice by that time
but when he spoke the rebuke before this
thing vanished it changed to its real form
he said it was the most horrible
thing he had ever seen and it vanished
i don't want to sensationalize god's word
but there is a being called the devil
and the devil's strong point i say is to get us to
believe the foundation of his deception is you're
not dead most of the world believes when you die
you're alive somewhere somehow most of the world
there are very few people who believe
when you die you in your grave
and the only ones i know who believe
that still are seventh-day adventists
others believe you die you come back as a
horse you come back as a a bird to atone
for some form of life you didn't get it right
the first time you come back and try you come
back as a nice cow you come back as an ant so
no one steps on ants you come back as something
others believe that's spirits of
ancestors and animals then trees
so they worship rocks their spirits there
they worship trees they worship rivers
we have to stand on a plane thus saith the
lord but let me tell you here in the united
states the devil isn't coming and trying to
get you to worship a god he is not stupid
we're too smart for that put that
word smart in quotation marks
but he will come with teachings that
look biblical using bible verses
one of the most dangerous is love
and that's all don't obey god's law
just love everybody because god is love obedience
is works that is satanic that is spiritualism
in its most overpowering disguise another teaching
just related to its time his twins all you need
is grace i'm under grace so i can live with a
man unmarried i'm under grace so i can go to
all wild parties on hollywood boulevard i'm under
grace i can smoke and gamble with all the money i
have that god gave me i'm under grace i can be as
immoral as anyone can possibly be i'm under grace
and people use god's grace for shield
for an umbrella from his judgment
and as a pretext or justification
for a life of opposition to god that
is the work of the devil do you hear me
do not ever read a horoscope
because all the devil needs is
a little opening into your mind
he just need you see the devil has six thousand
years he is he can be a little patient he he's
he has great wrath he knows that he has a short
time but that was 2000 years ago it's still short
but short for him and short for us his short is
this i was is that so he has a little time he's
patient he just needs you to believe that what
the horoscope writer said is true because the
devil can guide that person the devil is smart he
can say some things about the future that are true
the devil has power to work miracles that are
genuine revelation 16 13 and 14 and i saw three
unclean spirits like frogs come out of the
mouth of the dragon and out of the mouth
of the beast and out of the mouth of false
prophet for they are the spirits of devils
working miracles which go forth unto the kings
of the earth and of the whole world to gather
them to the battle of that great day of god
almighty the devil can perform genuine miracles
that's why you got to be careful with miracles
i was in a church i was in a thing in kampala
uganda one of my favorite places in all the world
and i saw a church name of the church
is uh um come get your miracle center
no the church is now to tell
you come get a miracle come
miracle's a business come get your miracle but be
sure to bring the cash but come get your miracle
the devil performs miracles your only reliable
evidence that you are where you ought to be is
got this minutes to eight i need five more
minutes somebody say amen please can i have them
five that's all five we done at five after eight
let me say that again jesus performed many
miracles he raised the dead peter raised the
dead there are some people in haiti who swear they
were dead and they came back they called zombies
part of the food and religion
this is the only absolute reliable
proof that jesus is who he said he was
not his miracles they play a role they have a
part but the fact that he fulfilled every old
testament prophecy about him is the most reliable
evidence that jesus christ is the son of god
does he work in miracles yes
miracles are a part of the gospel
but you must keep in mind
the devil works miracles too
so if you see a miracle somewhere what looks
like a miracle don't examine the miracle
examine the teaching behind it is there
confession of sin is there love for god's law
is there covering in the blood of jesus christ is
there love for ellen white somebody says something
i was reading it controversy today and i close it
not because i don't love it i love it but just to
give you reassurance i will keep my word five
after eight and tears came to my eyes as i read
because most people will be deceived
jesus prepared us for that the road to
hell many they be that go in there at
the road to heaven how many few christ has
prepared us that's why you should not judge
evangelistic success by how many hundreds are
baptized even though god desires to save hundreds
my time is up i can preach till 10
i won't it's a very serious subject
and god needs you and me to have our minds
fortified never read a horoscope never knock on
wood not even ingest don't even say the expression
because it has an origin it has a connection and
it is superstition the bible says a little
level finish it for me levels the whole lump
don't play with the devil to any degree fill
your mind with god's word our only defense
how many of you will say with me lord by your
grace open my eyes to see the deceptions of
the enemy can i see your hands yes raise them
high god bless you hands down you have cards
i want you to write something on that card
here's what you're right
here's the appeal i'm making
any man or woman who will say by the grace
of god i deny the devil and all his works
let me repeat because the cards are
distributed i deny the devil and all his works
i want you to put a large
d as in david on that card
it's eight o'clock we have five
minutes to do this and we'll do it
our commitment to christ tonight by the grace of
god and upon the authority of his word and the
power of his shed blood we deny the devil and all
his works put a capital d for david on that card
and as you write it satan your
heart as you write that he
say it in your heart by the grace of god the
power of his word the authority of his blood
i deny the devil and all his works that d ouija
board you used to play tell god you're sorry
everything's satanic dungeons and dragons
without they called it tell god you're sorry
it looks harmless it is satanic watching violent
movies that is satanic violence is not from god
watching pornography that's
satanic i deny it i deny it
large d and as you write it say it in your heart
the devil has to know that here at loma linda we
don't play we don't claim to be perfect but our
eyes are open and our eyes are on god we deny him
we deny him with every cell in our beings
we deny him in the name of jesus christ
now i want to do something else i just
want that d on that card nothing else
your response to this appeal i
want you to respond by standing
listen carefully don't stand to please me if
you will say father my only defense is the
word help me to find time to put your word not
only in my head but in my heart stand your feet
before we pray if anyone here has ever tampered
with the devil you've gone to which doctor you've
gone to a root doctor you've gone to psychic you
had tarot cards whether or not whatever you called
them red you've had someone read your palms you've
had satanic material sent to the mail any activity
of that kind and you're not sure you've repented
from your soul i'd like to see you sometime before
i leave i won't say tonight because someone
singing you may think oh that person's satanic
sometime between now and march the 10th before i
leave i want to see you so we can pray together if
jesus is lord of your life can i see your right
hand god bless you god records these responses
he really does he registered them in heaven hands
down let us pray father we come to you in the name
of jesus we thank you that every time the devil
tangled with jesus christ he lost he was cast out
of heaven he tried to kill jesus as a baby jesus
found refuge in egypt he put him on a cross put
him in a tomb sealed the tomb jesus came up in
our lives when we're faithful to christ their god
we the devil is defeated and one day soon when our
savior comes back he will wipe him out forever and
we cannot wait we pray in the name of jesus
you will accept our commitment our decision
from our hearts by your grace and the power
of jesus christ the authority of his blood
we deny the devil and everything that he has
to do and we place ourselves under the blood
of our savior at the foot of the cross on the
foundation of his unchanging immovable word
now lord if there's someone who has been in touch
with the devil forgive that person cleanse that
person completely from every satanic stain and
let that person stand in christ like purity
or father send the good angels to escort us home
because the enemy seeks to take our lives let us
not be concerned when black cats cross our paths
let us no longer knock on wood read horoscopes
anything of the kind but let all that comes out of
our mouths be the word of god and be seen in our
lives hear this humble prayer i offered in jesus
name and for his sacred all lovers of christ say
amen and amen god bless you god bless you come
back tomorrow sleep well the lord be with you
you